hi I'm Ike Barinholtz from the mini
project and this is I'd like to watch I
said an extra creepy because it's a
creepy sentence one of my favorite
videos is Australian man's barks like
dog so how is it that these two are
roaming their neighborhood frightening
the locals it's like a newscast about
like a dog that kind of like ran through
like a neighborhood and terrorized
people and it's just a nice old man with
his wife and as soon as they saw me they
came bounding this becomes possessed by
this dog and as crazy as he started he
goes I said then and then the dog left
and business I also do love it the old
like New York reporter talking like a
slum Lloyd I don't see that as being a
typical process nor do I is it a typical
process to you know I gotta go now I
want to thank you both thank you all
right it's back to you Julie and the guy
in the studio is like Oh is he still
there I want to ask him one question
okay what do you want what do want to
know well if I have to teach you how to
be a reporter Olli I'll do that later oh
yeah I do my job fine in fact I used to
be your boss these guys are on air doing
a news report and they bring up all this
personal [ __ ] I'll give you some lessons
on how to be an editor because I was
your boss once yeah you were and are no
longer how did that happen I also love
the one it's like a like a Logan looks
like it's like Florida or Miami or
something and it's at a local reporter
at some kind of like Seaport good
morning everybody I'm hanging out with
my friend John I was talking to a guy
who's like I'm one of those jetpacks
where it propels itself off the water
he's trying to get him to throw an intro
to the piece and he's like I'm here with
Mark he's in his jet pack Fox 5 Morning
News starts look over there and it
starts right now
and then the last one something with
like a goat whatever goat video people
send me goat me
my codes I my kernels and thank you for
watching I like to watch it's the
greatest YouTube is the greatest